each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning thank you all for coming
it's my pleasure to introduce our
speaker today professor Matthias Troyer
he demos are all the way from
Zurich where he is a professor of
computational physics at the Institute
for Theoretical Physics he's also been a
many time visitor at project q denim
station Q in Santa Barbara he's pioneer
of cluster computing in Europe having
been responsible for the installation of
the first Beowulf cluster in Europe with
more than 500 CPUs in 1999 and the most
energy-efficient general-purpose
computer on the top 500 list in in 2008
he's a fellow of the american physical
society and his activities range from
quantum simulations and topological
quantum computing to novel simulation
algorithms high-performance computing
and computational provenance he is the
author of the boost MPI c++ library for
message passing the unparalleled
computers and the leader of the
open-source Alps library for the
simulation of quantum many-body systems
so without further ado please join me in
welcoming professor trigger ok thank you
and what I was told often is that the
two words that scare computer scientists
and it's physics and quantum so I'm glad
that's so many we come here and I keep
it at the simple level where it should
be no problem to follow and if there are
people here who have some background
then in case you have questions ask me
and I'll show the details later what the
starting point is is that we see that
the most law still holds the speed of
the gay fastest machine still take out
the tift it's still getting in cases
this year export eventually and soon we
should reach an extra flop but the
question is how long can that continue
and essentially the consensus is that in
the next 10 years or so it should slow
down or stop the main physical
is that when you look at the gap the
CMOS device the insulating layer now
approach is about taking up the
nanometer so this for atomic layers
thick when you make it thin and scale it
down further then it will no longer be
the 50 insulating so there are you have
the challenges and one reaches the limit
of scaling quantum mechanics becomes
important but the main problem that we
face right now already is that as we
stop scaling we need more power to run
the machines because as we scaled it
down the power of the density stayed
constant now to get more performance we
need media bigger there are machines and
need more power so to get to a pc
petaflop and then get the extra flop in
the pizza past years were needed always
about 100 times more cause to reach
1,000 times more power so in the 90s i
used the abductor the hawaiian p and
they sounded a great machine ate CPUs
and get this flop then later Doug
to tell her dagger of the 50 use
machines with your thousands of course
and now my friends think of this did the
Japan they used their hundreds with bits
of trophy of thousands since of course
and that causes problem one problem is
Europe the unders law it gets just the
impossible to write good code or those
machines it gets hard to scale there's a
problem the code that we write scale to
about 10,000 course and beyond that we
can do simulations but they are not the
real problems we want to solve
so I'm not going for the better scale I
gotta want to solve the real problem and
not to get their record but the other
problem that we already face is power
the power that our clusters used gets
more and more and what limits our
clusters at the moment at the db2 ETH is
the amount of money the vice president
wants to give us to run the machine
therefore the power so I think that will
be the limiting factor so one can now
scale things up improve things slowly
but at some point in time there will be
an end and at that point we need to
change the way we do things and the
leadership users of community into
things that beyond 20 to 25 we need some
miracles so what we can instead to which
we can now already think about it
deceptive change and think how can we
make use of quantum mechanics in solving
some special problems in computing while
let the tittle of 50 moves law still
works the for a while now quantum
mechanics is carry too many it's what
caused them to the physics is what keeps
our keep others from physics like we
heard before the talk but it's already
more than essentially old and the last
century was essentially of physics and
there were many in innovations to the
physics but almost all of it is
classical they're very few quantum
devices and here i have a quantum device
that you can buy pass around it works on
windows mac OS and Linux so we have some
quantum devices that work like like they
are quantum you update aprender numbers
quantum simulators and May of this year
the first quantum computer was solved or
they call it the quantum computing
systems I will not talk about that
because I will talk about things that
work
I can mention something about d-wave one
if somebody asks later but I want to
leave that for now and I think my hope
is more for the future windows q quantum
computer that we might have some time
but now first to the machines that
actually work and why it's important to
actually make sure they work and what
they do you want to start with something
simple namely a quantum random number
generator and the question is where do
we need random numbers and where do we
need good random numbers of wife who
don't have a quantum random number
generator the main commercial
application for quantum random numbers
are the online gambling and lot of this
because they're you really want to be
sure it's random the lottery is really
have to prove that they are unbiased and
fair and so on and for the honor
gambling you don't want the hacker to
make use of some of the flaws in your
generator well it is what I did you stay
tative for simulations for quantum
systems instead this in physics then it
also you have a widely used the tin they
have the finest example of the possible
futures of the stock market and how do
we usually get random numbers we get
random numbers using an algorithm on
that hook up the listing machine and of
course that's not random because it
always gives the same results if you
start with the same input so it's called
a pseudo-random number and that's
something that just looks random that
looks and predicted the addictive lent
to and wants to do some fast simple
algorithms now the first problem is that
these numbers are not random at all they
are completely deterministic there's no
entropy and if you know the algorithm
you can predict the next number but it
might be good enough and some of those
does many many tests to the look random
are the relations and those that pass
the tests they are term to be good and
the number generators
and then a problem comes up every two
years that you do a simulation and you
calculate something with high accuracy
and defined recite this off by 40 other
bars that's just completely wrong
they've all seen the first time back in
your 19 and didn't have to haha 92 and
it comes up often now yeah famously came
up in 1963 or 64 already yep
pseudo-random generator IBM then used
for a generation you have to infamous
rental look at you shudder so it it's a
well-known problem and it comes up every
time when you use this better ones and
better ones and when test them and when
uses them and then a student spends
weeks finding a back in their code
because the test result is wrong until
the professor says it may be the power
of the random number generator and then
they say hey yes changing then one uses
a better one and then somebody runs in
and tells me there's a bug in my code
and I asked them have you change the new
number generator and it said why they
should be good so so the only test that
you have is your own application if that
gives the right result that is good
enough if it doesn't give the right
result then it's not good enough so we
essentially have to run everything twice
there are generators that are better the
ethical this take you one we tried
using them they at least if you find the
problem you have solved the heart
computational problem the problem is
they are about a factor of thousand to
ten thousand slow and they are too slow
they give to few numbers so the idea is
you can get a quantum and the number
generator and produce random numbers
based on quantum mechanics how does that
work it costs about 1,000 euros $1,500
and what is in here in here there's a
photon source that emits a photon and
the photon slides out and it hits a
semi-transparent mirror and here now it
does what you have to know about quantum
mechanics and the friend of mine shankar
dayal he explains quantum mechanics
using quotes from your
better there's a famous quote when you
come to a fork in the road take it
that's what really happens so the photon
takes the fork and it follows both paths
wait it came here then it follows both
paths and then we look where the photon
is is it here or is it there when you
look where something is then it's always
only in one location so by observing it
by measuring it and there's another Yogi
Berra quote for that that I don't
remember then it shows up in only one
location when you really pinpoint is
when you want to localize it somewhere
then it's only in one location and which
one is chosen purely at random there's a
physical mechanism here that could use
this randomness and then I record a
random pit 0 or 1 whether it's left or
right now does it work of course that is
assume that quantum mechanics is correct
and there's good reason to believe it so
does this device work and what you can
do is you can look up and there's a
certificate by the Swiss sort of the
office of metrology that certifies that
the tested device has all has passed the
negative that I have tests and it's
random so it's certified and then when
we saw our besides late and I to ask
them Nestle of course any certificate
only means as far as the test can tell
that's the first problem pious good
point it's not perfectly bet but
sometimes it gives you more once the
zeros or more sales than once what you
can do there is a version of this which
in the driver software does fun the
moment tipa tipa the biasing you take
two bits if the tubes are the same you
discarded the 01 you map 20 the 10 ml 2
1 that way the bias is gone and your pit
readies get used to a quarter so instead
of four megabit a second you get only
one megabit a second from the device but
without any bias one megabit the second
is
see is not fast because we we typically
need about the gigabit a second but
there's another problem when you look at
correlations there shouldn't be any
because quantum mechanics and that
should be perfectly random so we measure
the correlations and when you measure
for a few days then you find the East an
autocorrelation of about three times ten
to the minus five it's tiny but it's
worse than a cryptographically secure
pseudo-random number generator it is not
random now the problem here is not this
quantum mechanics is incorrect the
problem is that the detector has a
memory if the detector sees a photon and
the next time you ask you as a photon
then the detector can sometimes take it
again because of the previous photon
there's the photo punching sometimes
there can be two photons and then
there's a tiny bias that the same
detected like is again one can solve
that by just increasing the time this is
so if you go to about four or five times
the distance then is safe and if you had
used then the bit rate but not the
effect of 10 then you should be safe but
now we would use the bit rate by a
factor of 40 and you are not still not
completely sure that it works so what we
can instead do is I then talk to a
person in quantum information giving up
the corrado anna and he told me but hey
don't you use randomness x factor's then
i asked him what is that and then he
told me but that has been invented by
theoretical technical did the dagger of
the scientists just to produce random
numbers and that was then the key to
making this thing work what we do is we
view the bitstream not as a random
stream but as an entropy sauce and we
look at those bits and we be exact for
example billiard 2010 and you have they
update 48 bits of it and then we look
what
what is the entropy density in that and
two BS team a dozen find this about
point nine nine so there's only a tiny
tiny loss of entropy due to the bias and
the correlations and then one can do
this one can use it to learn in nevis
Elia the hash function one takes a
random big matrix that one fixes once
and for all and what does a
multiplication of the input vector with
that the bit matrix and from 2048 bits
of entropy that we feed in we can
extract one the 1792 bits of random
numbers and if this matrix m is chosen
with to handle numbers then the
probability to find any non randomness
in the output is less than 2 to the
minus the entropy density times the
number of bits minus the ones we
extracted divided by 2 and that here
gives us that we that the probability to
find any non randomness is less than 10
to the minus 35 if you want it even
better you just extract the struct fewer
bits from it so that way one can then
actually prove that the proper
disability that it's non-random is
pounded but by the type that you have
that number and what makes it work and
the only change that we need is a change
in the driver yeah the corner at reunion
the other question then are the less
expensive forms of event to be ye thats
Orton has to explore there are forms of
entropy that one could use for example
thermal noise another sister that's what
we're looking at the problem with
thermal noise is you cannot rule from
physical grounds that what the entropy
isn't the quantum device you know the
physical mechanisms you can actually
prove it with the thermal noise you can
estimate it so this is the the stronger
think but yes we want to find faster and
less expensive sources because that's
pretty expensive for a low bit-rate
doing the proof that you have there
seems like it not only dependent on your
controllable error probability yeah also
on the assumptions that you're making
about the correlation it depends on the
assumption yes it depends on the it
depends on what on how good my minute to
be estimate is and what is I'm just
going to that yes and so how did we how
did we get the number what we did is we
assume that the correlations decay
exponentially or decay fast enough and
the only thing for that estimate that I
need to assume is essential that the
correlation long times are bounded by
the values at the shortest distance that
the measure that went into the estimate
it just should not increase beyond that
level anymore in the future
if and that's the physical thing we know
about this device of course there could
be something hidden in in the quantum e
in physics beyond quantum mechanics or
they could be long term public relations
but but that's very unlikely yeah i live
on the heart of you but if cam random
number is only that problems are
perfectly good for crypto because the
bad guys don't have an interesting
advantage and guessing by the key yeah
here with keys are biased but okay the
okay profession yeah I guess I'm still a
little unsatisfied because of that
assumption because that assumption
doesn't seem to be any weaker assumption
than the typical cryptographic
assumptions that
good one-way hash function good to a
number generator
the assumption that goes in here is the
quantum mechanics is valid and that the
entropy that's the entropy is estimated
based on the assumption that the
correlations do not increase anymore
after a millisecond right is that in the
devices assuming a certain pseudo-random
generator secure
I think that is more secure because in
this device I can measure the
correlation time and the correlations
decayed with the autocorrelation time of
about the hundred nanoseconds and then
memory should be lost over time in those
devices and the time scale so
if you see that after a second things go
up again that would be worth a Nobel
Prize yeah
okay so now let me go to a device that
costs even 1,000 times more if you think
that was expensive now we go to
something that costs 2 to 3 million what
you want to do is you want to simulate
quantum systems and first let me show
you why simulating quantum systems is
hard why we need it and then what we can
do about it the basic problem is here is
the theory of everything is relevant in
daily life the Schrodinger equation with
Coulomb forces essentially physics knows
the theory of efficacy of your offer
everything unless you go to extreme
conditions this equation here the
Schrodinger equation explains most of
physics all of chemistry biology the
stock market life and more it's a simple
linear partial differential equation the
only problem is it lifts in three and
dimensions and n is of the order of 10
to the 20 so we just have to solve a
linear PDE in a huge number of
dimensioning the complexity of solving
that grows exponentially with the number
of dimensions if you have dipped effort
that they updated the end points in the
one dimension then you need to get
updated em to the free end points in n
dimensions so that's the basic problem
it's a simple problem but it just scales
horribly so we have to reduce it to
something that doesn't scale as badly
and since I mention Nobel Prize before
here's the first nobel prize to the
ticket to New York the corner poplar
what corn is proven and it's a one-line
proof so you can get a Nobel Prize for a
one-line statement that is that you can
find the ground state of a quantum
system not by finding this huge wave
function but the only thing you have to
do is you have to minimize a functional
of the density the density lifts in
three dimensions so you have to solve a
three dimensional minimization problem
you have to find the density
distribution that minimizes this
functional the only problem is we don't
know that last term he exactly that one
like poof that is
exists doesn't tell you how to compute
the earth easily it was recently shown
by the first route that izzy is hard
even on a quantum computer it is this
qma hard to find the two functional so
what people do they approximate and find
something that's good enough yeah it's
time for you yes it's some consistency
that's the exchange and correlation term
you have one term that is the external
potential gravity the nuclear and so on
you have the kinetic updated energy of
the electrons you have the classical
part of the Coulomb energy then you have
the rest that's tiny but important but
if you apply that for example to the tip
the silicon then you find the band gap
here and that band gap to accept it
cetaceans it is for makes the
semiconductors work now to solve this
equation you need big machines and to
demonstrate that i'm showing here the
fastest machines that run on the updated
jaguar in okage and essentially all the
codes in the world that exists that run
at faster than a petaflop solve this
material science problem this needs huge
machines and doesn't you know other code
yet reaches the pedal up so these are
big problems to solve this still and now
the question is can you find the
interesting things with it and one
interesting question is can be for
example find a good superconductor if
this super the conductor is the updated
material that is no electrical
resistivity and it was dis dis cover the
Becky Becky can be a 19-year elected 11
in Holland and as you go to lower the
temperature can get murky
a the ressies substitutability cops and
the wire carries the current without
assistance then it took nearly 50 years
to explain it and of course when one
when one wants to increase the
temperature which does happen because
the first one here was at about 4 Kelvin
which is very very cold here's now the
highest temperatures which the material
can be super conducting as a function of
time and it's cool slowly and slowly and
then is saturated at about 30 Kelvin
until in nineteen year 8 36 year plated
bad nose and Miller found the so-called
year after the high-temperature
superconductors and you suddenly it
jumped up rapidly in a few years to 140
Kelvin and is now stuck there the big
question is why are those materials here
the superconducting and the more
important question if wish if that was
in case related by a factor of three to
four can you increase it by another
factor of two and reach room temperature
and then we'd have ngupta to power lines
without loss it would be relegate
levitating trains and all so that would
be really useful there was a big hype in
those years about that will be happening
soon but since then we are stuck at this
temperature and the question is can we
simulate it so what we can do is we can
use the density functional theory that
worked so well for silicon and try to
apply to those materials and the problem
is and I don't want to go into detail it
just keeps the longer sides when you
have this material and doped in the
experiment it's an insulator when you
simulate it comes out as a metal it's
the it's qualitatively wrong and pick
just because here in those materials
this exchange-correlation term which you
don't know is so important so what's the
answer we need to solve the full quantum
probably want to solve a simplified toy
model at least for those materials but
we need to solve this big problem
and now i want to show you how we can
solve exponentially big problems and
what is the problem in quantum mechanics
what we can solve or what we can use to
solve height that dimensionally TPD's is
the monte carlo method that was invented
in the 40s by unum i don't know if you
know the story but he was seeking
embedding was playing solitaire and he
asked the problem that was also
exponentially hard namely what is the
probability to win in solitaire and if
you're 52 cards the 52 factorial
possibly games and if you want to solve
it exactly you either have to be very
very smart and find then accepted the
calculated the correct sector of
solution but he instead had another
smart idea he played a hundred times
because he had time and he didn't have
windows yet but the tiptoe he took
longer but then he played hundred times
in 115 times and so he knew that while
he didn't know the exact answer it was
somewhere around fifteen percent that
was good enough for him so if you just
want an estimate that we can get s Chris
I Cisco possible then we can do that by
sampling a small subset of the
exponentially large number of states and
the general algorithm for that was then
invented in 1953 so quite a while ago by
metropolis Rosenblum Rosenblum teller
and Teller and that's the metropolis
algorithm now many people have heard
about the methods but very few have ever
looked at the paper has anyone here seen
the paper the paper is interesting
because first of all there are two
husband-and-wife teams on the paper and
the person actually inventing the
algorithm was a woman a hipped it did we
unlike up they up to the Rose implode
metropolis was just alphabetically first
and he was the one who killed the
machine that machine was also special
because was the first machine that
rendered the killer flop it was a big
challenge at a time what to do with
such a fast machine and that's why tell
invented that method and that's what we
use now when we don't know what the big
machine is useful for the metals
everything will always work and it's
always important to find a good
motivation for a paper and find a good
first sentence into this paper piece
them all the purple this paid place to
describe a general method of calculating
the properties of any substance well
yeah including plutonium yes which is
still a challenge and there's another
sentenced and here the second one says
classic as the distance is assumed and
that's the problem for plutonium but
it's a simple method and they will just
show it because that will then point to
the problems with quantum systems what
you do is you start with any
configuration of your system of the
atoms whatever you make is more change
like you move one particle around you
calculate the ratios of the weight of
the new to the old configuration and you
accept the new configuration with the
probability that is the minimum of 100
ratio very simple but the a great idea
in principle it works for anything but
it's low and let me show you why those
weights might be the fittest the
amendment medigap the weight of a state
which is exponential of minus the TTD VA
and the energy divided by the
temperature in a classical system so
it's just the popper burger Pythia
you're pretty silly to be there in a big
update it a new updated temperature it
yet if you want to find the ground state
then essentially what it means you you
accept it always if the energy goes down
when it goes up you don't accept it
now let me try to show you how it works
and here I have a simple model of a
magnet let me try to run that and that's
a magnet that can point up or down app
is white and down it's black and I'm at
low temperatures and so it's just stuck
the simulation is actually running I can
increase my temperature and it starts to
fluctuate can increase the temperature
more now so hot that the magnet is no
long girl magnetic it's half black and
half white half up half down so it's no
longer magnetic now we can cool it down
again to close to the critical point
where the magnetism vanishes and now we
see that some pic domains you start
forming black and white ones and it
starts to all the way still half black
half white we also see that now nothing
much changes anymore and that's what I
want to show that those local spin flip
side due to changing squares from black
to white that does not change much in
the global structure this is called the
critical slowing down problem it gets
even worse if we lower the temperature
let me now go go again to very low
temperatures 0.1 it should turn white or
black and we can now wait a long time so
in principle it should work but they can
take forever and so we need to be smart
and event faster methods simplicity
works but we can do huge progress using
faster methods like let me go back again
to close to this critical point and
those cluster update schemes bye-bye if
they have dip the expense and one which
is the smart way to find the CAF to flip
and that code is about five lines long
as those 20 lines at the 15 lines end it
and it performs a factor of about 40,000
faster so that's a key that it's
important to find better algorithms
and to demonstrate that one of my
colleagues the lixia looked at at how
he's me you liked it the model over the
years and he started back in 72 and he
plotted how much did the walk computer
speed of his his machines increase that
was this line which assisted it's
essential should chill eager to follow
you up the most law and how much faster
did his code become with the combined
improvements of algorithms and hardware
and that was also an additional
exponential growth and in principle if
you run the modern algorithm on a 30
year old machine if you still had it it
would run faster than using the old
method on today's machine so they have
been speed up the fact of 10 to the 5 10
to the 6 and more just do two methods I
think one good point of the end of
Moore's law will be that will focus more
on methods instead of hardware but we
can now often simulate hundreds of
thousands of quantum particles the
progress came through the new ideas says
if the new methods but that's that
burger vector yo 10 to the five
faster we have another new method for
the plutonium that makes that effect of
ten to the six faster but that's used
now not by if this is that did a spur
but then gifted Livermore because I'm
not that interested in the update to
plutonium we scale our codes well to
about 10,000 course there are a few
colleagues to scale it further and get
the corn belt price by scaling it
200,000 course on on
up t official problems I prefer to stick
with the real problems and stop it to
dictate a 10,000 course for some codes
be you snuggle they updated the
accelerator chips like your ticket it's
a cheap use or leg of the successor
chips in the future and that helps a lot
and that L did they left it it allows us
to solve you have the typical problems
well we need to get those codes to run
is libraries that help us the scarcity
please provide the coding because we
essentially have to help a physics
student right the sensible code this
case well so we be used to me updated
did the libraries for that we be you see
updated workflow your systems that are
prob went Vernon see at the tip tip tip
tip enabled and this is the goal that we
reach now in to the papers or already is
that you that just by looking at the
pavement clicking on the figure you can
reproduce and rerun the whole
calculation and the next step which we
work on now is the new machines which
will get will not survive the runtime of
the codes i want to make the codes give
the portal event that works pretty well
for those simulations you want to have a
web flow system that helps you record
what you've done so when you you have
your site you gave at the end that with
that you have all the metadata that
tells you where it came from how it was
calculated if you just take your numbers
and you copy them into excel and make a
plot to copy that into your paper and
then you ask you hey hey which version
the code did you rendered on on which
machine then the students say i don't
know that might be the buggy versions
let me redo the whole calculation you
want to look at the final data and trace
the the lineage back back where it came
from
so with that we can for some type of
quantum systems which we soft up to tens
and hundreds of millions of quantum
systems but the most interesting of
those materials in the material that
there are electrons and electrons are
type of particle that the physicist
cause the Fermi on those who know
quantum physics know about the party
printable for the others I want to know
just that the effect is that you can
simulate those electrons but the weights
you get can become negative that goes
back to the question or snow of the
weights you sample the states and some
come in with a positive weight and some
with a negative weight so you get a huge
cancellation problem when you want to
sample it then you have a negative
weight then I want to accept the state
with the probability of minus one-half
and I don't know how to do that so you
then try to find a way around then we
could prove the solving this sign
problem in general is an np-hard problem
so we might find some cases where works
but in generally we will not and now we
come back to the quantum hardware
because Feynman was one of the first to
discover that problem and he said to
solve the quantum problem you know that
you need to use quantum mechanics so we
need to use a computer that is based on
quantum mechanics to solve it and for
those models we don't aim for a
full-fledged a quantum computer yet we
info a quantum simulator which is
essentially a special-purpose device to
solve a model and last year science has
chosen send the quantum you simulators
as one of the Pacific schools of the
year they had a total of ten scientific
topics for the break fools the winner
was a quantum machine the eight other
problems were all in in the updated life
science cancer research protein folding
and so on and one more was physics
namely the quantum simulators that they
passed the first key test and that's
what I'll tell you about now
so what are the types of machines that
we can have to compute the first ones
were analog like the antique tick tick
you're tearing up to the mechanism that
was a fountain click it's about 2,000
years yes only was the first machine to
calculate where the planets are nowadays
we have programmable digital machine now
what the quantum simulator is is
essentially a quantum analog of this
year I'm ticket etcetera machine and and
then an airlock look like a quantum
device in the future then that will not
take another 2,000 years but will be
fast it will be the quantum computer and
we I want to focus on how we can use the
classical machine to validate a quantum
simulator and that goes back to the
DARPA program on the optical Gallatin
lattice erupted emulators they said okay
that since people can build such a
quantum stimulator they give us money to
build it but in the first two years we
have to build one for model that you can
solve and we have to show that this
quantum machine gives the right answers
for a problem that we can solve and then
BB got something a bit more money to
solve some problems to build some that
we can solve from from this classical
machine but of course there's a
challenge to me and I try to make my
house fast and faster to solve the same
problem still so but what are those
machines built on it goes back to work
by the debate didn't play the bass this
buddy Steve Chu and others who is now
the Secretary of you update the energy
here and he found a way to cool and crap
atoms with the laser light that was the
Nobel Prize singer of the 97 and then
about four years later there was a new
Nobel Prize for the achievement of a
bose-einstein
set that will now mention quickly
clearly what that is and why it's
relevant to quantum simulators
essentially there are two types of
quantum particles that have been found
so far and your nature there are bosons
and fermions there's a third type d any
ones that you have the duty is the
digitization q looks for a fogger the
quantum computer but they have not been
found so far so we take a guess of atoms
down at very very low temperatures we go
down to the to the nano calvin
temperatures and clap a million of those
atoms and now depending on whether the
total number of neutrons protons and
electrons is even a lot it's a boson or
a fermion for example listen tip
lithium-7 is a boson and those bosonic
particles when you cool them down to
steal yo gurl temperature they all want
to go into the same state the fermionic
particles when you have the total the
odd number of the of the fermions like
an adept electron also they want to have
just one particle per state in in that
that's for example get the what explains
the shell structure of the atom you have
just one electron per state now bosons
are computationally easy in fermions we
get the same problem and they are
company and they are computed
additionally hard so model with bosons
we can lay up to simulate one with
fermions is then what you want to solve
so you can now build an atomic quantum
gas simulator it costs about 2 million
dollars because about two to three years
to build for a team if you know exactly
what you do the challenges are you have
these gases at nano calvin temperatures
you need to to to
the two to control the noise down to the
no Calvin you need to really line up
your lasers in order perfectly and you
need to be able to take the negativity
pictures of the atoms so it's a big
challenge to actually build it but then
then once you built it what can you do
you still need to show that here in this
glass chamber there's the quantum gas
and then what they do to to find the
stages they take the gas and they drop
it down the top this cloud of gas and it
expands then they just take a picture
fish and that picture now shows that gas
cloud and what it does is it shows the
velocity distribution in the cloud those
atoms which we address just stopped down
those who like a flying out they've play
father so once you take the picture you
see the the the the momentum
distribution of your of your cloud and
that's where this pose an interesting
condensate comes in if you have bosons
at very low temperatures they all occupy
the same state so they all are at the
rest in the center of the tap when you
know now drop them down they shouldn't
fly apart because they're all in this
state addressed and here are the three
pictures as they cool down the gas a
sharp peak formed in the center at
velocity server and they found the
bose-einstein condensate and they got a
Nobel Prize now can we do more okay
that's a simple gas but now we want to
simulate a more complicated model like
four electrons in a the material for
that we need to add the crystal lattice
now we can do that but just adding an
optical lattice by adding six more
lasers and six more beams and all and
then you take those six laser beams to
form a standing wave pattern of light
and then you have those atoms hopping
around on the lattice
now you build a quantum lattice model
and all you have to do now is you have
to build the model that describes your
affective the material and the measure
its properties does it work we want it
to validate it so we can simulate the
same number of your atoms of a button
you have four million atoms if they are
bosons on a pick lettuce and a
single point takes about the update to
eight hours on a single core so it's
cheap but then we have to be had to
model all the details the same lattice
structure the same number of particles
the same temperature we measured the
same quantities and then if this quantum
device work then our simulation should
better give the same results as they
measure if not then the corner device
doesn't work so we compared and of
course it didn't agree why did not agree
and that's because we have to model all
the details of the experiment then we
learnt that it drops down only finite
time so there's still corrections to
what you actually see is not the
limiting value which is the velocity
distributions then we have this lasers
and there's some noise in the lasers
that nasal noise heats the gas so the
temperature changes then we have a lens
through which we take the picture the
lens broadens the signal that we see we
have the camera with the pixel size and
once all of that was taken into account
and looked again two things agree and
this is what we got at the end this is
the decimal ation this is the experiment
and here's slow-tempo gender the high
and essentially increase except that the
simulation is still clean it has the
smaller hours when we look more closely
than it's just wonder they'll go the
full kept agreement here
so it works that's the good news so we
can actually build a device that
implements a quantum model and when we
see simulated yes the device really
gives what you want so we actually built
a quantum model in their quantum device
now the next step the next step is we
want to solve the heart problem for
example we want to solve a high
temperature check up the superconductor
what do we have to do for that if you
want to do that on a classical computer
it becomes an exponentially hard problem
if you want to do that on the quantum
simulator we just have to change the ID
to the isotope like we just have to
change from within 72 lithium ate the
rest of the machine can essentially stay
the same of course there are our
engineering limited problems but that
can be done and it's not much harder for
them to do fermions and bosons well for
us from the classical the machine is
much harder to do the fermions what's
the state is there to validate it it's
much much harder it's about both for the
small systems at high temperatures
they're at now it's about the factor of
a thousand harder but we could validate
the first results and we now wait for
the first things that we didn't know and
those those numbers should come soon
from them if we want to simulate a real
material like you mentioned the
plutonium there's no way we will ever
model the lattice structure of that in
such a system so for that we will late
the needed their your cut the quantum
you have to the computer but simple
models one can actually build and then
measuring so one can build a
special-purpose quantum device to solve
hard quantum problems so to summarize we
have the diversity of quantum devices
and they seem to work like the
cryptic quantum guaranted thumb numbers
as work they're a bit slow and cost a
lot but it works the quantum simulators
cost much much more but that's deserved
it the next stage and slowly they will
reach models and give the 50th the air
temperature regimes that will not be
solved on the fastest machines so they
will be updated to come use for quantum
computers would be the next step but in
my point of view you shouldn't sell a
quantum computer before you validate it
that it works so that will be the next
thing to do then that was funded by
DARPA I mentioned and the bigger again
the objective to Center on quantum
systems and take a good technology where
we work on quantum dots simulations
cubits and more and the people who did
the work for the quantum a random number
see it was sega student erupted cafe leg
ahsoka in near 32v the samee yugioh
relations but done mostly by flow the
palette at the 50 th and the experiment
immense bubble butt done and get it done
in your place munich by stefan Trotsky a
student there thank you yeah listen
Paula computer you can't measure them so
whatever doesn't matter with it
what's the Sabbath wonderful feeling
super mega deal tomorrow hey there for
quantum computer now okay so in a
quantum system when you measure
something you will change the state of
the system is that what you mean and
that's exactly what those quantum random
numbers are based on because if you say
the photon is in two places and you
measure it somewhere then you change the
system then it's in one place only but
which one is chosen randomly and that's
the process that the data are and there
lies the device so that that when you
measure it you have have some random
selection and that's what we use for a
quantum computer you want it to compute
a single answer that you can measure
just and it's just II in one state at
the end
yeah hey if I remember right AES
encounter mode runs about to side was
permitted and it's secure enough for
NIST and NSA what we need to slow for
you if you run the standard block cipher
encounter yes if you get stuff that
whose only distinction from
pseudo-random is that is that tell you
there's no birthday paradox is that
really too slow
two seconds per bid that would be slow
compared to some of the ones we use but
it would approach the range where we
invited well notnot oh yes yes so where
it can be useful for some methods the
ones we tested and we try the vapor they
need about just so 10,000 cycles per bit
yeah
so but with any of those generators the
basic thing is there is no underlying
guarantee that does end up in your
stream but in principle it is always the
administering so they can always be
problems and yes there is the potential
that we don't know the physics yet that
makes this device have some strange
crockett attestations of the long times
but that's less likely than the other
being a problem in one of the
pseudo-random number generators so it's
at the different level because cause
this device does have some to entropy in
it which the other metals don't
hmm
wait
any more questions